hello everyone and welcome to not one
but two games uh from yesterday's uh akd
phylicia's arena uh you guys requested a
couple of games and i thought uh well as
hikaru won the event let's show uh a win
uh or a rather some nice games by hikaru
and who better than hikaru against
magnus and hikaru against alireza
because it's not very often that we see
them playing in in uh well in the same
tournament on the same platform so the
first one we're not gonna analyze we're
just gonna gonna show it because it's
too short to be analyzed it's against
magnus and the magnus of course uh goes
for the bomb cloud he went for the bomb
cloud every game uh in the second half
of the tournament so let's check it out
and then uh let's uh enjoy the game
against alireza as that one is a little
bit longer so here magnus played f3 uh
he go this is basically the the mr
barnes opening but you have to go into
this the to play the bomb cloud you have
to play f3 and then king to f2 so hikaru
grabs the center very principle d5 we
have king of two uh the bong cloud is on
the board even though this is still
considered the barns actually uh e5 we
have e3 knight to f6 and here d4 by
magnus we have e captures on d4 uh e
captures on d4 and now bishop to d6 so
if you can develop the king here will
not be uh all that all that better piece
but for for bullet it might be even even
good so bishop to d3 hikaru castles with
knight to e2 and now c5 uh attacking the
center so c3 and hikaru uh trades here
we have captures captures and knight to
c6 so nothing special happening here
knight b to c3 and queen to b6 makes
sense as the king is on f2 you prevent
white from developing the bishop you're
also hitting the b2 pawn and you're just
threatening to capture this
so knight to a4 puts pressure on the
queen queen to a5 and now bishop to d2
developing while forcing the queen to
move uh bishop to b4 now hikaru offers a
trade of bishops and magnus goes for it
bishop captures we have queen characters
and a3 now chases the queen back and now
finally queen d2 developing the queen
connecting the rooks and that's uh uh
that that's okay so rook to e8 and rook
ate the e1 and it seems that magnus uh
uh did everything that he needs so he's
gonna play rook to f1 for the moment he
can't if he plays the rook to f1 then he
loses the h2 pawn so he still has to
wait with this he carl plays b6 and now
comes knight a back to c3 uh we have
bishop to d7 and knight to b5 now
attacking the queen queen to b8 and here
the position is even uh slightly better
for white but magnus played queen to f4
and it was uh well in this position that
hikaru
won the game now i'm sure you guys don't
need to pause the video because you
already see it so i'm just going to give
you a couple of seconds to you know
fully experience it of course magnus
offered the queen trade but hikaru
eliminated the defender of the queen
with temple and that's it here magnus
resigned that's that's the game of
course after the rook is captured
doesn't matter what you capture it with
the queen will be eliminated
and that's it so this is the only game
hikaru and magnus played in the
tournament uh which is all i thought
they'd play a lot more because at some
point i thought they will both be at the
top and then they will get paired um
together all the time but as magnus was
always trailing uh behind he was uh
i i think the best he got was like
fourth place but then he got
10th place then 15th in the end i think
magnus finished 12th
so this is the game against magnus and
now uh the game against alireza that you
guys also requested a lot so here in the
tournament uh hikaru played four games
against alireza three of them ended in a
draw and did this one uh well perhaps it
did not so let's let's check out this
one so hikaru has the white pieces and
he opens with e4 we have e5
knight to c3 going for the vienna game
knight to f6 and the g3 so a little bit
uh
different than what you would see in
you know longer time format so it's not
exactly the king's gambit but it's also
very very uh enjoyable so c6 bishop to
g2 and now alireza uh very very very
principled uh strikes in the center with
d5 we have d3 defending the center and
bishop to b4
pinning the knight bishop to d2 and now
d4 chasing away the knight knight c to
e2 and now bishop captures queen
captures and c5
alireza grabs more space in the center
and now
we have h3 by hikar we have knight to c6
uh and f4 now uh nicely nicely played as
you always play this f4 movie in a
vienna at some point uh we have castles
and knight to f3 we have knight to d7
now preparing f6 and hikaru just castles
we have f6 here uh uh setting up this
very strong control of the center and
now already might start advancing the
pawns on the queen side so c3
undermining the center now queen to e7
we have captures on b4c captures and now
even g4 here uh hikaru is preparing uh
this f5 push but uh uh
it doesn't seem to be all that
troublesome for for alireza so here a5
we have rook 8 to c1 and now even a4 uh
trying to create some weaknesses on the
queen side we have knight to g3 and now
all it is i should just continue uh
pushing on the on the queen side either
capture on f4 or the immediate queen to
b4 or for a queen trade but he goes for
g6 and this kind of creates a weakness
for hikaru to hone in on so f5 uh we
have g5 and now h4 hikaru now forces
open the h file then he's gonna play
king to f2 and then well hopefully
double rooks on the h file so here we
have h6 h captures on g5 h captures on
g5 and now king to f2
uh we have queen to b4 by leaders and
now offering a queen trade but now
hikaru of course declines he prefers the
queens on the board he controls uh much
more space so you do not want to trade
down rook to f7 and now rook to h1 now
you're ready to play rook to h6 and
hopefully double up on the h file knight
to f8 and now rook to h6 we have bishop
to d7 uh ready to bring the other rook
into the game now knight to h5 putting
uh more pressure on this f6 pawn so
knight to h7 defending it and now hikaru
could bring the other rook to h1 and
well prepare uh the attack but he goes
for rook to g6 check first king to f8
and now king the g3 the king will be
much safer here so there's no need to
rush anything
we have king to e7 and now rook to c4 uh
further harassing the black queen
making the queen lose uh
such a valuable diagonal so queen to b5
uh maybe the d3 pawn can be pressured at
some point as it is the base of this
pawn chain so if you can eliminate one
uh then the entire pawn chain will will
collapse so here are queen to c2
rook to a5 and now we have queen to d2
again putting pressure on the rook if
the the position opens up if maybe the
knight and queen move
let's say you move the queen somewhere
weird we can eliminate the knight and
then pick up the rook so here he brings
the rook back and now queen back to c2
and now knight to b4 attacking hikaru's
queen queen back to d2 and not knight
back to c6 so hikaru can't seem to
figure out how to
advance uh
uh further in the position but now he
does bishop to f1 now the pawn is nicely
defended and you can make progress here
alireza goes knight to f8 he attacks the
rook and now it seems like you have to
move the rook but it's actually a
completely winning position for hikaru
uh so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the the quickest way to win
this while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course rook
captures on f6 i mean everything is
winning here you could capture with the
knight you could play rook to h6 but
real captures on f6 just makes uh makes
sense uh so here uh okay you have to
capture there's really no better move
now comes uh knight captures uh on f6
king captures and of course queen
captures on g5 so you're down material
but you will start advancing those pawns
and it's not going to be easy for the
black king to the perio of this so queen
to h6 king to e7 alireza trying to
escape now g5 we have queen captures on
v2 and now g6 uh there is really nothing
to do here you have to give up
the knight for for that pawn knight
captures f captures and now bishop to e6
now at least you are guarding the
queening square and you are putting
pressure on the rook here so queen g7
check king to d6 and now even rook
captures in c6 check not giving black
any counter play b captures on c6 and
here queen captures on e5 again with
check king to d7 and now hikaru has to
continue queen g7 check uh or queen f6
or something to continue playing this
but he plays knight the g5 and he gives
alireza one small chance to get back
into the game but it's bullet you can't
see everything of course look at this
diagonal uh queen to b8 just forces a
queen trade and if uh
if alersa plays this then it's pretty
much over captures captures and now it's
going to be white who will be fighting
for a draw he's down the exchange okay
he's up a pawn but still yeah it's not
going to be easy however after knight g5
alireza missed this and if you miss this
there's really no no good move this is
hanging and there's no way for you to
actually to actually defend this if you
play queen captures on a2 uh then again
we just play queen to g7 check and then
well the king has to go up the board uh
because if you go king d6 then e5 and
then you're just going down the board
and you will lose this terribly for
example king d5 queen to e7 and now you
are getting checkmated this is hanging
this is being threatened the king can't
go anywhere uh so really really really
bad uh but uh like i said queen to c1
was played here uh and now it's again
not much better queen captures an e6
with check king to c7 and now queen to
f7 check we have king to b6 and now
queen to f4 offering a queen trade you
are
up materials or if the queens get traded
off then you have a bishop and knight
against the rook and you have a very
nice pass pawn on g6 so queen to e1
check queen to f2 now comes queen back
to c1 attacking the knight so king g4
now comes rook to g8 we have queen
captures on d4 with check
uh king to b7 now comes queen to f6 we
have queen to d1 with check king to g3
and now queen to e1 with check in here
we're just gonna have a long series of
checks uh because well if alireza can't
hold hold on to the position here then
hikaru just wins so king d2 uh queen to
d2 with czech king f3 queen d1 check we
have bishop to e2 blocking and now
finally uh queen the h1 with check king
e3 queen to g1 check king to d2 and now
rook to b8 but now of course uh hikar
just advances the pawn g7 we have king
to a7 and queen to f7 check now ready to
uh promote our pawn to a queen queen a6
and now first e d4 uh opening up this
discovery this comes with check king to
b6 and now g8 with queen now car has two
queens and that's pretty much it queen
captures on d4 check bishop to d3 we
have rook captures on g8 there's really
nothing better captures we have queen
theft to check king to d1 and now queen
to g1 with check king e2 we have queen
g2 check now comes king e3 quincy to
reach your king d4 uh queen to d6 check
and king to c3 so a few more checks uh
before alireza resigns uh but uh you
know you you you have to do this always
king to c2 queen to h2 with chuck king
to d1 now comes queens you want your
king d2 queen to g to check bishop to e2
and here queen to g1 was played but it
was also in this position that alireza
uh resigned the game as there is nothing
more uh to be done here
so very nicely done uh hikaru uh beats
both magnus and alireza and doesn't lose
a single game to them and these are the
standings um just so i don't forget so
these are the top ten hikaru wins first
place andrew tang wins second and drops
on that david paravian russian
grandmaster uh wins third place then we
have yakko baby uh that's not rebecca
yakubu of uzbekistan
uh i'm still not sure who japeto is a
lot of you guys were saying that's
nipple uh but it says on his profile
that he's from italy so i'm not really
sure about that although it could be him
then artemyev in sixth then what
uh that's uh opervezen if you remember
him from leeches uh uh vincent ruthas we
we made two videos about him a very very
strong international master especially
in in speed chess then nine king 96
that's uh alexander boternick also
russian grandmaster grandmaster whatneg
i don't know who that is i'm pretty sure
i knew but i mean i can't remember all
of them and mutt pro that's uh
international master min lei fro from
vietnam so there were many many grand
masters in this event it was a very very
enjoyable i enjoyed the streaming i hope
you guys enjoyed watching it uh we we
mostly covered the the top players uh
but uh you know pretty much everyone in
the world streamed this event so i'm
sure you can find
um you know
your favorite players on some of those
streams at least and especially if you
guys have like a really really cool game
that we can cover uh do suggest it and i
will cover it i already have one of my
favorites i think uh yeah
uh
uh another kubo have played a brilliant
brilliant attack in gaming the evans
gambit so we're gonna cover that one
probably uh but you know still deciding
you know do use hashtag suggestion and
we'll see what happens
uh so yeah that's the game uh the games
i hope you guys enjoyed that and hope
you guys enjoyed this event a big
congratulations to hikaru for winning
the entire thing that's uh that's no
small feat
and uh yeah a big big thanks to kkkd5
for for sponsoring the event so really
amazing stuff it was supposed to be an
end of the year event but you know as
the tournament broke down it had to be
shifted over to the next year uh but
still uh hope you guys enjoyed this
christmas arena uh but yeah uh those
were the games hope you guys enjoyed
that i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to anna and i would like to
thank robert stetleman ryan urban
patreon and andrew dinihan for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day